welcome to kids class hooray it's the
last day of May so tomorrow is why
closed but he was so close he gets a
prize right but you don't get any cigars
because you were close okay today Shh
today is you get the Quebec we're going
to talk about checkmate and we're going
to talk about why you checkmate somebody
the main reason is because I said so but
there's other reasons okay we're going
to talk about having more force we're
going to look at some games where people
got checkmated and the reason was the
other player had a lot of pieces
attacking their king did they have one
piece attacking the other king do they
have two did they have a billion at
least at least you have to have more
chess pieces than people in the world
otherwise you won't be successful all
right here's the game I played in 1992 I
think most of you were there watching
the game and it was played in your
favorite country armenia's clause but
the correct answer is France okay that's
close right because your favorite city
is there Marseille anyway so in this
position nobody is getting attacked yet
and white is threatening the bishop
although that's not very close to the
black King is it we better get some
white pieces over there so we can check
meet him then I can collect my prize now
I don't want to make anybody cry but
this was 1992 so the prizes were in
French francs you guys really upset if
this was played today wouldn't the
prizes be in Euros now we're talking
okay at the term was in Greece it would
be in Euros
alright so black played bishop to be
seven saving his bishop okay what did
Private Ryan say about that
exactly all right now we have to go
attack the black King we have to attack
with all of our pieces so I move my
pieces towards blacks King and then he
cried that's why I brought Kleenex to
the game you unknown person Queen c2 I
could but I'm going to retreat even more
this was France so I really knew how to
retreat that the kids all got that by
the way for those of you at home yes in
the back that later
so I played 94 for our now I want to
mess you up
I'm going to take this way and this way
then you're going to cry so he took my
knight and my rook was very happy see
the smile on my rooks face now my rook
has the green light to go you see I have
a pawn in front of my rook as we say in
French
nothing email no pawn in front of my
rugged I took with a pawn yay now my
rook is good also my son is pretty good
okay he played pawn to e5 now I can't
move my Center pawn hey if I illegally
take on for Sonic and win hmm okay so
now if somebody suggested earlier the
Queen must retreat Queen d1 is my queen
gonna check made him here what would the
German say they'd say ich don't think so
but if I play Queen d1 now my Queen can
come over here and check meet him so he
gave up no no not yet okay
so he played rook to e8 and I put my
Queen near his King okay and he tried to
take my queen what did I ever do to him
well yeah that's right so I he played
Bishop to see a and his Bishop is lined
up with my queen so now if it was his
move he could move his Knight away
attacking my queen
yeah so I move my queen again queen h5
rawr okay
and he played Bishop a6 attacking my
pawn because he's mean and I said you
could have my pawn because I'm going to
checkmate you notice I bring more and
more pieces near his King and he moves
pieces away from his King okay so he's
like yeah a free pawn and I'm like yay a
free King okay so now I'm ready to go
I'm ready I got everything lined up he
played app six and I played this
scariest move you ever saw you have to
be seven years old to see this move it's
really scary it's rated PG 7 you Lea y 7
I did take on h6 that's because you're
10 so you can say that damn almost
I'm almost 11 - I'm only 34 years away
all right now if my opponent takes my
queen the computer will get mad it's
like no you can't do that because my
rook is here what's my rook doing to his
pawn pinning it what kind of pin
relative or absolute absolute now I'm
threatening checkmate because I like
checkmating people what vitamin distract
may have e vitamin C for checkmate I'm
threatening checkmate if you don't like
that checkmate then I can play this
checkmate is that okay so what did he do
to stop checkmate
did he let me check with him or he
stopped it what did he do to solve it
what did he do no he didn't do that
because then I would check meet him
later he played rook f7 defending his
pawn he's mean
now I saved my Bishop Bishop c2 and he
played in the center d5 and I was like
oh boy answer yeah so I took his pawn
and now look at my great Bishop that has
vitamin B for Bishop if I went to the
6th rank then what vitamin vitamin b6
you know you guys okay so he blocked my
Bishop with e4 this move is so tricky
and here's why it's tricky see when his
pawn was here see and now it's here you
agree see his queen rarh
so the reason i can't take his queen is
because king but if it's his move he
could take my rook and now he can take
my queen you see my queen on h6 then I
lost a rug so did I let that happen
a player of my caliber no I retreated
because I was in France queen h5 I hope
MVL likes this lecture ok now he played
Queen c8 because he retreated and I
played Rock h3 ah the rook and queen are
about to make a battery on his King if
you want to checkmate your opponent
using a queen and a rook is a good idea
exactly ok he played Knight FA Larsen
style and now let's see I got a text
maybe it's the right move it that
probably was really loud in the speaker
because it was right next to it so you
gotta do some editing ok wait we have a
move here yeah I just got a text with
the right move
Wow very impressive now who's my
favorite player ever very close
the me is also a good answer no not you
at home sitting on the couch now you're
not my favorite player you're like my
second favorite player okay his initials
rpm because it's the afternoon Paul
Morphy there you go
and Paul Morphy when he was attacking he
used all of his pieces he didn't use one
piece he used all of them which white he
all of them even the King pieces off the
board pieces in other countries
he was like give me all the pieces now
in this position which white pieces of
white not using the rook that rook does
nothing now I'm the expert on doing
nothing you can ask anybody so I was
like wait a minute that guy's got to go
do something
so I played rut to e1 attacking his pawn
mm okay and now he made the losing move
although he's already losing so how did
he do that okay
he made a move that loses really fast
because he wanted the class to end so
you guys could go up and play your
tournament game that's what a nice guy
he was okay he thought I was nobody you
know why he thought that because I was
nobody so he's right and he's like hey
if I attack his Queen he won't see it so
he attacks my Queen is it he a mean guy
now I'm a nice guy if you want my queen
you can have it if I got a microphone I
can drop because I got a guy out of here
wait did you like my move yeah wait a
minute is this a microphone BAM
all right what this is a microphone you
know now you you you're shorter yeah I
agree with that you know he didn't even
do that first he started crying and then
he gave up
I mean crying I could understand but
giving up well I'm supposed to wait hold
on yes I am he told me to wait now I
have to weigh more I hold on I'm waiting
you sure you should you should
double-check your analysis is it double
check all right if he takes my queen I
play double check using this Bishop at
this rook so he has to go here right
answer that's your question okay
your questions never mind all right so
check me and then I win notice I use all
my pieces my bishop was scaring him my
rook finally came out all my other
pieces his pieces are over here away
from his King he doesn't need nearest
King and the one piece serious King
stops his King from moving
aha okay so then I won and he didn't
hurray for my pieces okay next game was
against everybody's favorite board
member
Doug accurate right is that your
favorite board member Jim's like yeah
why not okay now here this is a game I
played last year it was Thanksgiving he
had nothing to give thanks for that he
didn't get tortured for many moves got
be quick so my bishops attacking a
little drunk this bishops attacking my
Knights coming and his pieces are over
here so let's check me at him how's that
yeah I agree okay so he tried to get his
Bishop out should my bishop jump over my
pond you kids are so mean can I just do
it once the people at the home were like
yeah yeah do it do it I'm gonna do it
yes
wow I'm really good okay so I took his
pawn and now my bishop is wide open
that's a good Bishop right
he took my pawn now I don't have a lot
of pieces attacking let's get some more
pieces 95r okay now my bishop is
attacking my other bishop is attacking
my Knights attacking and here comes my
queen so first he cried then he resigned
from the board in shame right you agree
with that man Jim's like oh that didn't
have us resign from the board mache many
times like No alright so black played g6
blocking my bishop that blocks my bishop
let's pretend he didn't block my bishop
doodoo now I take his knight which way
should he take with the pawn of the
Queen
if you takes for the Queen BAM
attacking your queen and your ruck yes
he takes with a pawn
then vitamin C is coming Queen h5 and
then and then lots of trash-talking not
not not a small amount a large amount
now I'm threatening check me good luck
stopping it I wish you luck who's going
to stop checkmate you're going to stop
check me you can resign that'll stop
checkmate yeah no reason I'll do it
you sure rook e8 and then I go check and
check me if you don't like that then I
can go check and checkmate
if you don't like that I have other
checkmates okay so he didn't let me do
any of that because he's on the board he
played g6 blocking my bishop
or he went back several most for no
reason okay now we need more pieces to
attack how do we get more pieces to
attack we play buck house then our
partner gives us lots of pieces but I
wasn't playing buck house this is real
life so yeah get my queen out now
my Queens attacking his knight and my
bishops attacking his Knight do you know
how much he cried it was a lot yeah
that's right cry him a river now I just
showed you the game from France so you
know that black retreated Bishop e7
defending his Inayat I need more pieces
to attack who's going to give me more
pieces so I played Bishop b5 attacking
his knight mine my knight
I don't like he let me take his knight
though but I wanted his Knight okay now
here was my idea it was really long and
crazy ready for my crazy idea he moved
his knight backwards too - too much love
of French food if he went here I was
going to play something crazy okay I
take his knight he takes my bishop and I
go here because I want to play Bishop
takes Knight and then checkmate so he
played nine to be eight I mean I thought
he did okay now if we play another chess
game he set up for the next game good
job okay more attack efore all of my
pieces attack everything is attacking
now he played a6 attacking my bishop I
saved my bishop he took my pawn i took
his one do I have enough pieces
attacking all my pieces attacking look
at look at this guy did he develop his
Queen side wait I saw my turn
now I'm threatening to win this night
because I have three guys on his Knight
that's a lot of guys on his Knight
so he played 19 tonight Bishop takes
Knight threatening his rook did he save
his rook what's the only way to say it
is rook yet to move your UNK
okay now I play the move that's so good
everybody in the room cried not just my
opponent you do what is it
Queen c3 is not a bad move would he'll
play f6 but your moves pretty good I
sacrifice because I like to checkmate my
opponent
you know vitamin C so I played nine
takes eight seven attacking his rook and
winning upon so now he did something
crazy don't tell anybody
Shh close your ears at home no he did
something crazy he gave up let's pretend
he didn't give up what would you like
him to play Martin King tanks game now
White has checkmate in two moves who can
find it White has checkmated no need to
raise your hand no screaming yeah
Queen h3 almost works except he can
block with his Bishop because he's a
mean guy and now his Queen protects his
bishop but you're almost right you've
never been so close yeah well that's a
legal move I'll give you that then he
takes it and I cry how do i checkmate
him nobody knows
Oh bathrooms over there
Queen f8 yeah man that's risky you know
a risky over here well you don't know
I'll call on you Queen h5 put it in H he
can't take us of this silly bishop
vitamin b4 bishop now he has to play
King g8 and then checkmate notice the
bishop on b2 yeah
so after 1987 he resigned resigning was
a good move yeah answer make him
movement while his rook is attacked what
would you like to play rook e8 Man
Knight f6 check I mean I feel sorry for
you and also night at 6 tracks probably
a bad move but it's pretty good take the
knight
III think White has an advantage when I
say White has an advantage if I was in
the hospital had one day to live and I
was playing Magnus Carlsen he'd cry
forever that made a lot of sense right
now
now I'm threatening your queen and I'm
also threatening checkmate
and then you resign resigning is good
because then you don't get checkmated
Queen here here then I go here and then
I go here
yeah exactly right okay
now the last but not least before your
tournament game I played priyadarshan
who always beats me and what do I do
when he always beats me cry this game
there was very little crying from my
side okay so in this position I'm black
my bishops attacking his King my Knights
attacking his King Queens coming down
Knights okay
only my rooks they do nothing our my
trucks attacking his queen is king let's
do something about that
so I played Knight a5 attacking his
queen but he saw it moved his queen now
I played rook b8
rah here comes the rook he took my
bishop but I saw it I took back he moved
his knight to defend rawr rook takes b5
he played 93 rah Rigby 8 now all my
pieces are attacking right everything
rawr okay are these pieces defending his
King no terrible okay I have five pieces
attacking his King don't cry it's okay I
had black okay
he played King c1 to run away where is
he running to where is he going he can't
he can't go here I'll take his King
I can't I'm a grandmaster
he's only international master exactly
see somebody's learning okay
now nine to c6 because the knight was
blocking my queen now I'm threatening
checkmate checkmate is good because I
win
Queen a1 check me
how does he stop check me well the best
way is to give up but he chose a more
logical way before now his queen is
defending see how his Queen wasn't
defending and now it is defending see
what he did there
all right now I was very hungry because
the game took
for hours so I was really hungry so now
I started eating puns mmm mmm
lots of roughage night takes b4 I showed
this position to a grandmaster and he
cried for a week because he had a
nightmare and thought he was Wyatt yeah
and then he woke up and realized it
wasn't his game you agree Paul Paul
didn't see this he's going to cry what
do you got special
little scary we have a text from a
grandmaster don't show me that I'm
scared yeah okay yeah so man that's not
good so now he did something better than
I've ever seen before
the computer says he should give up his
queen and then I play pawn takes Queen
they say that's the best move for Wyatt
alright let's see who can play white and
avoid checkmate
if you last more than three moves you're
the best who can play white and last
three moves without me check reading
them who can do it you can do it or I'll
play resign okay how about playing some
moves now I have to warn you I'm
threatening Knight a to checkmate so be
careful yes you absolutely the computer
gives giving your Queen away for a night
now you know I here designed yeah that
also gets checkmate abut you last longer
yeah so blacks threatening Knight a to
checkmate and as some of you would point
out it also wins the Queen that's even
better than check me right now no all
right so since black has all his pieces
attacking and he's winning y-you gave up
now it's time to go to the tournament
next door if you're playing wait are you
playing my room oh good answer